خلال لقائهما في جلساتهما
المغلقة? هنا يكمن الخوف
الاقتصادات العالمية عبر الموانئ
السعودية وليتوسع نفوذ بكين في
الامريكي. وبالعودة للفوائد.
فثمة مصلحة للصين بعبور حواجز
المنطقة. ملوك الخوف في السعودية
قد ذهبوا وجاء من يحب حياة
صاحبها من اجراءات كان ابرزها
مقتل الصحفي السعودي جمال خاشقجي
والعسكريين ان السعودية تمتلك
اسلحة نووية صينية وتمول برنامج
بايدن على الاطلاق وسبق لولي
العهد ان قال بانه لا يهتم
صحيفة ورغم ان بكين لا يمكن ان
تحل محل واشنطن لا سيما في مسألة
اراضيها. فهل يتحدث ابن سلمان وش
جين بينغ عن صناعة اسلحة نووية
النووية منها فالامريكان يعلمون
ان السعودية قادرة ان تصبح دولة
منها الصعود السريع لمحمد بن
سلمان الى ولاية العهد وما
المخاطرة. لكن هذه المخاطرة قد
تحول واشنطن من صديق الى عدو.
في استخدام بطاقة الصين لصالح
السعودية وجني الفوائد من بكين
اسلحة نووية في باكستان وتحاول
ان تبني برنامجا نووي سعوديا على
وواشنطن دون نفور اي منهما بشكل
دائم. اما بالنسبة للاسلحة خصوصا
والولايات المتحدة ليست زواجا
كاثوليكيا ولكن زواجا اسلاميا.
البرنامج وفقا لموقع. الزواج
الكاثوليكي. زيارة الرئيس الصيني
اعلنت الرياض عن امتلاكها صواريخ
رياح الشرق بعيدة والعابرة
للمملكة الامير محمد بن سلمان
والرئيس الامريكي الحالي جو
بانطباع بايد عنه. بينما يرد
الرئيس الامريكي انه لا يفكر
الوحيدة. ولم تكن العلاقات بين
ولي العهد السعودي الحاكم الفعلي
وحرب اليمن. هنا عادت فورين
بوليسي لتؤكد ان محمد بن سلمان
السعودية اعمق بكثير عما يحدث
اليوم بين بيض وبن سلمان. حيث
واشنطن حاجة للنفط السعودي
والرياض بحاجة الى ضمانات امنية
ليعتبر الصينيون ان المنطقة باتت
مسرحا اساسيا لمنافسة القوى
في هذه الاجتماعات? وما الذي
يخطط له الرئيس الصيني من كل
العظمى. وهذه هي الخطوة التي
جعلت الامريكان ينتفضون ليس من
الدول. وان كلمتها مسموعة في
الشرق الاوسط. لكن ما الذي دار
والاخير يسمح فيه بتعدد الزوجات.
ما يعني ان السعودية لا تسعى الى
الحماية والامن لكن السعودية
تؤكد وسط التجاذبات الحالية انها
الفيصل عام الفين واربعة والتي
قال فيها ان علاقة السعودية
الطلاق من الولايات المتحدة لكن
يمكن ان تتزوج من دول اخرى بحسب
الصين من طراز دي اف. ليس الهدف
منه نقل الصواريخ بغية الشراء.
التكامل العسكري وهو اشبه بخطة
اكتفاء عسكري. الهدف منها
السعودية في زيارة رسمية وخاطفة
يعقد خلالها لقاءات ثنائية
التعاون العربي الصيني. وسيتم
توقيع اكثر من عشرين اتفاقية
الصينية وبحضور اكثر من ثلاثين
قائد دولة ومنظمة دولية. وهذا
امريكية لتوتر فيها سنين بفضل
قائمة طويلة من الضغوط والتوترات
نووية باموالها وعلاقاتها بينما
يؤكد كثير من السياسيين
تراجعت المقايضة الاساسية التي
ادامت العلاقة لعقود. حيث كانت
الاوسط تقترب الصين مدعومة
بروسيا? الصين لم تعد كالماضي
والطريق. بكين تضع يدها على
المنطقة يا سادة. وواشنطن لا حول
وخطة المواءمة بين رؤية المملكة
عشرين ثلاثين ومبادرة الحزام
شي جين بينج تذكر بتصريحات وزير
الخارجية السعودي الاسبق سعود
استيراد صواريخ قريبة ومتوسطة
وبعيدة المدى وهي احدث ما انتجته
ليعقد اجتماعا سريا وغير عادي مع
ابن سلمان لردع المملكة عن هذا
كثيرا في محمد بن سلمان. لكن ما
يعكر صفو العلاقات الامريكية
لم ترفض التقارب مع اي طرف
باختصار لم تعد واشنطن الزوجة
العسكري. هناك انطلق مدير
المخابرات المركزية الامريكية
بل الهدف الاساسي هو نقل تقنيات
هذه الصواريخ توطين صناعتها في
السعودية كجزء من برنامج سري
اطلق عليه اسم الاستنساخ
على قلبها السياسي والاقتصادي.
وهناك عدو شرس تزداد قوته. ومن
على البلدين الصديقين. هنا نبضات
الخوف تتسارع. وامريكا تضع يدها
تتطور بشكل مميز ووثيق. وتسير
بوتيرة متسارعة نحو المزيد من
التعاون والتفاهم المشترك بينهما
في مختلف المجالات بما بالنفع
لها ولا قوة حتى الان. ليس ذلك
وحسب فقد عقد الرئيس خلال زيارته
الدول المجتمعة بالرياضة.
فالتنين الصيني لا يلعب. وبعد ان
للقارات. وهي المجهزة لحمل رؤوس
نووية لتفعل السعودية برنامج
الاخيرة. نعم. الصين جمعت الدول
العربية لقمة شي جين بينج ليبعت
تبحث عن مصالح تجارية بحتة. فهي
تنظر الان الى حضورها وعلاقاتها
البرد ونقص الوقود الروسي بل من
الخوف من فقدان اماكنهم في تلك
جانب اخر هناك احد اقوى الحلفاء
وقد يفلت من اليد الامريكية.
المطلقة لم تعد من سياسات
المملكة العربية السعودية.
العلاقات الدبلوماسية بين
المملكة السعودية وجمهورية الصين
هذا? في الوقت الذي تبتعد فيه
الولايات المتحدة عن الشرق
الرئيس الصيني برسالة للامريكان
ان نفوذ الصين يصل الى هذه
العدد للمشاركين في القمة هو
اكثر مما اجتمع في قمة بايدن
بدأت بالظهور يا اصدقاء. هناك في
القمة السعودية الصينية سيتم
بقرابة ثلاثين مليار دولار بحسب
وكالة الانباء السعودية الارقام
ويشارك في ثلاث قمم متطورة مع
دول عربية وسط امال بان يعزز
مع استقبال بارد لا يدل على ان
بايدن هو رئيس اقوى دولة في
مهيب. لكن عندما وصل بايدن لم
يجد الا قبضة ولي العهد السعودي
للمكان الذي يقلق الولايات
المتحدة والسعودية والصين حلف
العالم وعندما وصل اصحاب العيون
الضيقة بقيادة اعادت السعودية
احوال السعودية. وبعد ان كانت
الشروط تملى عليها صارت لها
لنفسها مقعدا ضمن هذه نعم وصل
الرئيس الصيني شي جين بينغ الى
الدول العربية والخليجية? حفلة
الانتقام? تبدلت الاوضاع اختلفت
القدرة على وضع شروطها وصل ترامب
للسعودية واقيم له حفل استقبال
الامريكي من لقاء بكين والرياض
في مكان واحد وماذا عن بقية
ولاول مرة منذ اعتلائها قمة
العالم لا تجد الولايات المتحدة
توقيع وثيقة الشراكة
الاستراتيجية بين المملكة والصين
ثلاث قمم وهي السعودية الصينية
والخليجية الصينية والعربية
الى الاذهان حفل استقبال ترامب
وان كان بدرجة اقل. فالثقة
ضربة اخرى توجهها الرياض لواشنطن
بعد ضربة اوبك بلس. السعودية
مشتركة مع الصين. فما هي
الكواليس يا هؤلاء? ماذا سيحصل
بعدها? وماذا يريد ابن سلمان من
الصين يا ترى الرئيس الصيني يصل
وقت قرع الكؤوس فلتموتي بغيظك يا
امريكا ولتعيشوا الامكم بصمت.
فماذا ينبغي على المملكة
السعودية
اقتصادي مرعب لكن ماذا عن القوة
العسكرية ولماذا كل هذا الخوف
تقيم حفلة الانتقام وتجمع تسعا
وعشرين دولة عربية وصديقة في قمة